Eternal's assemble. Are you a wizard like doctor
strange I'm super normal Welcome back everyone
this is my non-spoilery marvel eternals movie
review one of the biggest cosmic movies that
marvel has ever done next to avengers infinity
war avengers endgame if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
once the movie does come out in theaters i will
do my full breakdown video easter eggs post credit
scene videos and more videos about really specific
things that they introduced during the film
also we have a bunch of hawkeye episodes that i'll
be doing videos for in a couple weeks as well i
won't be including any big spoilers in this video
that i haven't already talked about in my other
trailer videos but if you've also had a chance
to see the movie early please do not post spoilers
for the ending or anything like that on this video
so the eternals movie is all about introducing
this really weird group of characters created
by jack kirby a long time ago marvel hasn't ever
really done a ton of stuff with their characters
inside the marvel universe because for the most
part the x-men the avengers other big groups have
been way more popular so the comics just tend
to focus more on those groups when kevin feige
revealed they were doing an eternals movie when
they were developing one it had been before they
got all the x-men characters back the fantastic
four characters back from fox so a lot of people
just assumed that they were doing eternals a
sort of proxy for an x-men movie but the really
exciting thing they wound up using the movie for
was to tell this really giant cosmic story that's
way bigger in scope than most of the other movies
that they've done not only during marvel phase 4
but also marvel phase 1 phase 2 in phase 3 aside
from avengers infinity war in avengers end game
gonna be a little while before we see a movie
that's bigger than those but they use the movie
to tell the true origin of the mcu the sacred
timeline version of history starting with the big
bang we've seen a couple versions of that in the
previous marvel movies with them talking about the
big bang the creation of the infinity stones they
use the movie to give you the actual origin of the
universe itself the origin of eternity the origin
of the celestials the formation of the celestial
host some of that you've seen in the trailer
there's arishem the judge hargen the measure
jemiah the analyzer nezzar the calculator issan
the searcher who we saw during the guardians of
the galaxy movie it also helps provide context for
other rogue celestials like ego the living planet
who isn't a celestial in the comics but they made
him a celestial inside the mcu so the eternals
movie helps you reconcile all that backstory
like how do all these characters fit together
also answering questions about nowhere the head
of the dead celestial because there's been so
many theories about that if you're not familiar
with the marvel cosmic hierarchy it starts with
eternity that's sort of the living embodiment of
the universe eternity is born during the big bang
eternity creates the celestials they form into a
group called the celestial host they're created
for the express purpose of just going around and
experimenting with life in the universe to that
end they wind up creating eternals and deviant
characters all over the universe the movie does
a really good job of explaining all that history
without getting too bogged down in the details and
they leave a lot of things for sequels to explain
like obviously there's the thanos of it all thanos
comes from another group of eternals that lived
on the planet titan somewhere else in the universe
they also give us the true history of the earth
the history of humanity evolving on earth and it
sort of recontextualizes everything that we know
about all the marvel movies so far the whole idea
that they get across in the trailer they've been
here this whole time for all of civilization how
they interacted with all these people across time
how they affected all the other marvel characters
because clearly as they reference all the other
avengers characters they've been aware of what's
been happening in all the marvel movies so far
there are a couple points in the film where you
are meant to question who the real antagonist is
like they present the deviants like they're meant
to be the villains of the film like crow is the
leader of the deviants but there's this thriller
mystery element to the movie too where the
characters are learning that they've been lied to
this whole time and you start to learn who the
real villains are throughout the course of the
film and i don't think it's a spoiler to say
that the movie doesn't really get into too much
of what's going on with kang in the multiverse
because we learned during the loki series that he
who remains king had basically been controlling
the multiverse in the sacred timeline his main
timeline for all time i'll talk more about details
like that after the movie comes out because we
kind of have to get into spoilers and talk about
some of that stuff but the eternals movie tries
to give you the truest version of history like the
original version of history whereas he who remains
kang and all the other kang variants were messing
with the timeline the movie also is starting to
give us a version of an origin story for the
black knight character in the mcu through kit
harington's dane whitman although it really it's
only briefly touches on that in this first movie
kit arrington is sort of the fish out of water
character who serves as the audience surrogate
and he does a great job at this it's kind of funny
to see him in this after watching him in game of
thrones for the past 10 years you can make all
the game of thrones jon snow jokes you want kit
harington's dane whitman knows nothing he does
know a couple things after the end of the movie
also there's the funny meta aspect of the game
of thrones reunion because we have richard madden
playing ikaris so they have a bit of a game of
thrones reunion during the movie even though their
characters don't spend a lot of time together kit
harington and richard madden did say that was one
aspect of the movie that kind of excited them like
that they would get to see each other and work
together again after such a long period of time
gemma chan was amazing as sersi they brought her
back after captain marvel to play a completely
different character in the mcu but she looks
sounds completely different i feel like this
movie made much better use of her because she's a
fantastic actress and they really didn't do that
much with her character during captain marvel
which is one of the reasons why i think that kevin
feige wanted to bring her back like he saw her
during crazy rich asians and it's like oh you're
a fantastic actress we need to do something better
with you salma hayek plays ajak sort of the leader
of the eternals at the beginning of the film
she's kind of like a big sister to the other
characters of all the eternals her portrayal
of ajak her version of ajak is probably the most
different from the comics angelina jolie was great
as thena character she wasn't quite as big of a
character as I expected and i'm always curious to
see what they do with these really big mega stars
when they put them in movies like this especially
in ensemble movies brian tyree henry plays phastos
he's sort of like the iron man of the group he's
the person who makes things so he's actually a
pretty interesting character it'll be fun to see
him interacting with other marvel characters when
they do big crossovers in like avengers 5. kumail
nanjiani is playing kingo they use his character
to make a lot of connections and easter eggs to
other marvel movies and other avengers characters
in funny ways i felt like they could have done
a better job with sprite and druid during the
movie their writing for their characters is just
a little bit weaker so their scenes just don't
hit quite as hard as the other character scenes
but there are 10 eternals at the beginning of the
movie so it's inevitable that they're not going
to be able to serve every single character really
really well that's why they didn't start out with
10 avengers they started out with the course 6
and then spiraled up from there in the sequels
you've probably been hearing people talk
about how the movie feels so much different
from other marvel movies the best marvel phase
four comparison i could make would be to a movie
like the shang chi movie which we just saw a
little while ago so the shang chi movie is meant
to be this kung fu action film about a family the
eternals movie is also kind of about a family like
a cosmic family but even though there's a lot
of big cosmic action in the eternals movie it's
really more of a character drama about the family
itself so the movie focuses more on the individual
characters interactions more than it does the
really big action scenes so it almost shares
more in common with the new dune movie than it
does with the other traditional marvel phase 1
phase 2 and phase 3 movies it's a lot more chatty
than the other marvel movies there's a lot more
of the characters just walking around and talking
to each other than there is in other traditional
marvel films the pacing is pretty decent it
does drag a little bit during the second act
but when it does go big it goes bigger in scale
than any of the other marvel phase 4 movies so far
outside of avengers infinity war avengers end game
which are technically marvel phase 3 movies but as
i said earlier it's metaphorically the biggest
story that they've told so far because of the
way they invoke all these cosmic characters
like the celestials in the universe itself
it's kind of like them doing a dune or a star wars
story inside the mcu with the scope of everything
for long time marvel fans they do answer a lot
of really cool long-running questions about
big events in mcu history like why didn't the
eternals help fight thanos if they're so powerful
did the eternals get snapped i feel like
it's not a spoiler to say no they did not
get snapped because they're kind of more like
celestial robots than actual humans they share
more in common with vision than they do the
humanoid adventures they also get into their
relationship with the other avengers characters
and other heroes and villains from earth like
they've mentioned the avengers character several
times during the trailer like even kit harington's
dane whitman character invokes doctor strange
when he's learning about all their new powers
and they do use a lot of small moments to connect
the movie to other movies inside the mcu and just
like the shang chi movie introduced this brand new
mythology these brand new characters to the mcu
all this big storytelling on a cosmic scale
but it was relatively self-contained like you
didn't see a bunch of other avengers characters
running around in it it's the same situation
with the eternals movie really big weird group
of characters really big cosmic story but it's
relatively self-contained movie i think the idea
is that when we get to the eternal sequels then
you'll start seeing other avengers characters
crossing over a little bit more and if you have
been following all the news they've already said
that some of the eternal's characters will show up
during avengers 5. just in terms of the timeline
what's happening right now in the mcu the turtles
movie is supposed to take place around the same
time as spider-man far from home which is about
eight months after avengers end game as you see
with most big marvel movies there's a traditional
mid credit scene and the post credits scene both
of them do set up really big things please don't
post spoilers about them in the comments if you
have seen them but long time comic book fans and
long time marvel movie fans will probably like
one more than the other and as i said because the
movie is relatively self-contained there aren't a
ton of direct connections to the upcoming marvel
movies but they do have moments that sort of
foreshadow what's happening next in the mcu
because the next big movie is literally spider-man
no way home and they're calling that movie
spider-man end game behind the scenes
like that's how big the movie is in scope
and right after that we have doctor strange
2 multiverse of madness which is going to be
probably one of the other biggest movies during
marvel phase 4. the music was also fantastic i've
talked about this in my previous video just a
little while ago but ramin javadi did the music
for the movie so if you're a big fan of the music
from game of thrones you will love the eternals
music i think for most marvel fans mileage will
vary with how much you enjoy this movie depending
on which avengers movie your favorite was like did
you like avengers infinity war more than you liked
avengers end game because infinity war had way
more action like was much more of an action film
avengers end game was much more of a drama
film eternals is much more of a drama style
film so even though we haven't had that many new
marvel phase 4 movies i would say just ranking my
favorite marvel phase 4 movies so far it would be
eternals number one then shang chi number two and
then black widow number three but we've only had
three movies so far so i'm also kind of expecting
spider-man no way home and doctor strange too to
sort of shake up that list because those movies
are going to be so big but once you do have a
chance to see the movie just post your reaction in
the comments below and like i said my full easter
eggs breakdown video post credit scene videos
we'll all start posting after the movie comes out
in a couple weeks everyone click here for my new
eternals doctor strange trailer video and click
here for my new spiderman no way home trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!